tony blair you've come here today to
make an argument that there shouldn't be
a general election somebody think that
an odd even an uncomfortable look for a
non conservative politician why don't
you want an election if there's a
deadlock in Parliament and Parliament
can't reach an agreement and the Prime
Minister feels his hands are tied and
Parliament is insistent he cannot take
Britain out of Europe with no deal
because that was never contemplated and
we decide that the right way is to go
back to the people to break the deadlock
then you should go back on this specific
question of breaks it because it was
decided originally as a self-standing
question on its own and it should be
reconsidered on its own so in principle
yes of course at a certain point there
should be an election and decide what is
the government but if brexit is the
reason for deadlock in Parliament and
you want to resolve that deadlock then
you should ask the people specifically
on the issue of brexit not mix it up
with the general election where all
sorts of other questions come into the
mix but you have yourself made arguments
in previous general elections that
issues are decided in elections whether
it's 9 7 2001 some of the big questions
that you settled isn't a bit odd you are
making an argument that Jeremy Corbyn
himself was a factor so the question is
is brexit an issue that really is on its
own out there as as a different type of
issue that crosses normal party lines
and the answer to that is yes it is and
we know that because it was originally
decided in June 2016 by a referendum now
if in the end Parliament can't agree
what form of breaks it and Parliament
and government are in a situation of
deadlock and you've got to break that
deadlock then you should go back by the
same means that you originally took to
the brexit decision and the reason why I
I fear that the Conservatives may want
to do a general election not go back and
ask people specifically on braces it's
because they think they can mix the
brexit question up with jeremy corbyn's
leadership and then hope to get support
from people who may completely disagree
with No Deal breaks it but say for
whatever reason fear the Corbin
Premiership more that's the wrong way of
doing it if
if the issue is brakes it decided on its
own luck knee who knows what's going to
happen this week but it looks quite
likely you're not going to get your way
and there will be an election and we
might not get to a second referendum in
that election would you vote for labour
and Jeremy Corbyn well it's gonna be you
know difficult because of all the
disagreements I've had with the Labour
leadership but on the other hand I feel
passionately about about brings it so I
think if you if it comes to an election
we're gonna have to see is there a way
that you can construct a majority in the
country against No Deal but all of that
just underlines why an election is not
the right way to do this I'm not quite
hearing a yes
yes or no you you're hearing a qualified
yes but the anxiety is is obviously
because there are things that I don't
agree with in the rest of the programme
of labour that's precisely why you
shouldn't force people to decide the
brexit question through the medium of a
general election thing forgive me a
qualified yes means that you might not
vote Labour
or you will vote Labour with a heavy
heart well qualified yes means this that
I have big worries about the labour
party program we have to see what the
manifesto is but my overriding desire
will be to stop brexit or a No Deal
bracelet which I think would be very
damaging for the country but you know
about would definitely well you can't
say that and that's why it's difficult
to judge at this moment in time I will
do in an election whatever is best to
stop a No Deal breaks it but I think
it's wrong and I'm just like I'm just an
example of what will be facing millions
of people if you have a general election
it's wrong to say to us that when the
issue is brexit
we're forcing you to make that choice in
a general election where there are host
of other questions around security the
economy state of the political parties
that come into a general election so
that's why you know I'm not I'm not you
know give me a definitive answer of this
stage to that question but my the very
fact that I'm not shows you what the
problem is the problem is that in a
general election you'll be deciding
brexit but you also be deciding a whole
lot of issues has nothing to do it
breaks it to remove all into the future
we're one year on from an ideal brexit
can you sketch out what you think that
looks like has Britain done a deal with
the European Union eventually has there
been a change of government is there an
overthrow we still in a stalemate people
don't articulate what that outcome could
look like the the problem with with
saying what No Deal looks like is
literally that no country modern
developed country has ever done this
before I mean no modern developed
country has ever D liberalized this
trade in this fashion and no modern
developed country has ever gone out of
its preferential trading agreements
overnight with no agreement in in its
place so when people say to me what's no
deal like I always say I really don't
know I mean if you can't articulate how
can you argue it it's a bad thing
competitions need to do that don't they
if they're on that side of the argument
for sure it's an enormous risk now is it
difficult or is it damaging or is it
disastrous that's less certain although
I think most people have looked at this
in detail say it's towards the
disastrous end of the spectrum if it
happens we're gonna have to find a way
of trying to make it work and you know
I've always said to people once Briggs
it's over if we've done it you know
we're gonna have to try and find a way
of bringing the country back together
and making it work but it's because you
know those of us who study this think it
really is an unacceptable risk to take
that we're taking the position we are
nihilist everybody in the country is
board would break sit on board would
raise it everybody is but you can't it's
too big a decision to say look I'm bored
just do it I mean and that's where a lot
of the public is because the
government's continually both the reason
they actually now Boris Johnson
continually saying although any disease
MPs would stop being obstructive you get
their deal but they're not they're
actually looking at the detail which is
what they're supposed to do in a
parliamentary democracy and they're
saying well this is a difficult
difficult thing to do and we can't
responsibly just decide to do it because
it suits a particular faction in the
Conservative Party